I've had 20 best sellers in a row and
not one of them has sold to more than
one percent of the US population
which means that 99 of the US population
said nah not interested no idea who you
are see ya that's not failure that's
success don't make cereal because cereal
ends up being popular because something
had to win that day's Lottery but it's
probably not going to be you and instead
put ourselves on the hook and say no I'm
making this for the vegan community of
Agora Hills California and if they don't
like it I have failed whereas if I say
I'm making the best thing I can and
hopefully lots of people will like it
well then when a few people don't like
it you can just say well I'm waiting for
the next people I'm waiting for a lucky
break how do I hype this and so putting
yourself on the hook that's how you get
funding for your project that's how you
hire people that's how you get a job
what it means to win on the long tail is
you're just a tiny drip in a giant
bucket and that's enough